gaudin ski au conseil de développement
de saint quentin en yvelines créée en
2002 cette institution consultative a
été renouvelée ce jeudi 20 octobre sa
mission donner des avis et émettre des
propositions sur les politiques locales
notamment sur saisine du président de
l'agglomération
il s'agit aujourd'hui de faire un codé
ski pour douze communes n'étions que
sept auparavant pour douze communes et
je souhaitais aussi apporté quelques
modifications c'est à dire jusqu'à
présent c'était le président de
l'agglomération qui nommer une grande
majorité des représentants la voix j'ai
souhaité que ce soit la mère qui soit
beaucoup plus influents dans la
nomination de leurs représentants le col
skis composé de 96 membres représentants
d'associations de conseils de quartier
de l'université du tissu économique
tous les acteurs du territoire saint
quentinois peuvent y siéger c'est un
travail de partenariat étroit qui nous
permet d'avoir un regard près du terrain
sur des réflexions qui sont aussi
variées que l'aménagement du territoire
que le développement économique que le
travail associatif sur la culture et le
sport
on essaie d'avoir un panel représentatif
de notre population pour que chacun
puisse nous donner quelques réflexions
quelques suggestions entrepreneurs 58 -
depuis près de trente ans il fut hachée
été nommé nouveau président du coc des
skis
j'essaierai d'être de chef d'equipe
d'une équipe qui aura à traiter d'un
certain nombre de sujets et de grands
dossiers qui seront pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux
proposé par l'agglomération je pense
notamment aux grands projets de
territoire qui est un sujet majeur est
important et qui va sûrement nous occupe
est incertaine - les membres du code est
ce qu'ils vont se réunir prochainement
pour discuter de ce dossier et réfléchir
sur les autres sujets pour lesquels ils
pourraient donner leur avis